all right welcome to mastering the
middlegame
or as I like to call it grand mastering
the middlegame
so today we're going to look at three
games I've never seen before except I
saw the middle one already so that's
called what would me twelve say there
you go
yeah yeah what's wrong with you people
another usual okay now these middle
games are going to concentrate on
checkmating attacks the only thing you
understand if I'm like white as a slight
advantage you're like wait a minute I
wonder what several of those words mean
slight advantage White has the oh we
have a follow Grandmaster walking that's
good okay slightly late even though he's
early terrible okay obviously ken west
okay so first game is from Foxwoods a
tournament which no longer exists but it
used to exist and when it did exist it
was over Easter and then Foxwoods
casinos like get out chess players are
cheap so now then they had nothing now
they have a turn to Philadelphia I don't
know okay and then you know nobody else
would Easter is anyway okay so this is
Nakamura shadowlaw from 2005 when
Nakamura was a good attacking player and
Chad woth was less old okay so the
players were slightly better now they
played a boring Queens gambit declined
sort of like didn't you show where'd he
go didn't you show Queens gambit
declined yeah yeah and then he played
see takes d5 in your lecture was the
same thing okay now in this position
engine in say John strand and John
strand says lecture black played Bishop
f5 if black doesn't play Bishop f5 now
he'll never play it now I have an aside
which he may or may not record which
lecture are you putting on the web first
his or mind is okay so you've seen
John's lecture several hours ago and now
you know that Bishop f5 was played in
the game Carlsen kramnik I wasn't really
participating in the lecture I was busy
on Hotwire also I already analyzed
the game of Fabiana Cara Juana and he
was like how did white get at five and
he was all mad like cram mix the worst
okay and it turned out Kramnik isn't the
worst but Klaus okay so if you don't
play Bishop f5 now you're never going to
play it and of course shadow off play
Bishop d6 and you suggested Bishop e7
was the most common and na can wear play
Bishop d3 now Bishop f5 is risky okay
you might pre move it in a 1-minute game
but Queen c2 beats you Bishop d3 b2 so
yeah okay so the problem is black
doesn't have a great square for his
Bishop but after Knight f3 shadow I was
like aw I'll play Bishop to g4
I can't go to f5 g7 is silly east six is
silly because it blocks the rook g4 is
great now you may have noticed one of
the two players white decided not to
castle because he didn't know where to
castle yet well since black played h6
it's very difficult for black to trade
off the bishops which he likes to do by
playing Bishop h5 to g6 because then he
just loses upon what White has too much
force there well if black plays Bishop
g4 and he's not going to play a Bishop
h5 to g6 what else is he going to do
take on f3 so nakamora like well if
you're going to open the G file then all
Castle queenside you'll open the G file
I'll meet you I'll mark the result up
it's an American Swiss there's no art
beer that comes you know okay this is a
long time ago and shabal I was like yeah
it's sharp I like sharp things like I
waited and I'm playing Nakamura darn
okay so Knight bt7 and he's like h3
let's go take my knight I dare you I
double dare you
and then in a very strange coincidence
Nakamura said they speak English in what
very strange conversation they had okay
so this should be h5 to g6 loses upon
white just plays g4 Matt Larsen style
Bishop e6 as a strange move because it
blocks the rook on EA and also white got
h3 in for free so why it's going to play
G for an attack so
took tonight okay White's pawn structure
is man the white has two advantages got
the open G file and he's got the two
bishops okay White's King is pretty safe
Queen a5 now anybody who is my student
or as listed to my lectures and has less
brain damage than most of you at home
remembers my rule always play King b1
very good now come where knew that rule
before I espoused it I guess that's why
he's top ten in the world and you guys
are top ten and now some of you our top
ten in the room more than half of you
all right
usually don't give the audience a hand
but they're oh wait a minute somebody
just came in no now less of you were in
the top ten
okay so King b1 now a two is defended
forever so if my Knight wants to do
stuff and I'm running away with my
pieces you're never going to play Queen
a - okay and I wasn't really sure if you
were never going to take on a two so I
asked and vogue and they said never
going to take on EA two and I was like
all right and then like two people got
it and at home only one person got it
well darien got it - you left a little
right well a little bit okay so and the
rest of you are never going to get that
joke never going to get it no not never
going to get it okay so King b1 and
obviously since white play King bee one
black resigned now we'll go to the next
game oh he didn't resign oh never mind
okay Shabanov played Bishop e7
retreating like a Frenchman now why
would you play Bishop e7 you got me I'm
guessing Shabanov wants to move his
night either Knight FA defending or
Knight b6 attacking and if you move your
knight now this show takes f6 is good
for white so Bishop e7 then we'll move
our Knight
okay rg1 very obvious now this is a
middle game where we castle opposite
sides in those middle games
whoever checkmates their opponent
usually does pretty well I'll let you
write that down if you're taking notes
okay and when one side is attacking and
the other side is defending
and the side you're playing against
never attacks you
yes sir Sarah one would say it's a free
attack and so chaparral played rook AGA
I don't know what that's got to do with
anything
and rook G to caveman chess double rooks
and crush them on the G file King H a
double rooks rook GA came in a bughouse
even black's losing even worse okay and
Nakamura can't really do any more that's
Paul Eakins stands he can't stands no
more doesn't like spinach so e4 he's
trying to win on the Kings side now he's
winning in the center this is the other
problem with taking this tonight it
helps white strengthen his center and
I'm sure it reminds all of you it
doesn't remind any of them about the
Braunstein Larsson variation of the
caro-kann right well one person nodded
and then he looked like this you'd be
careful I'm watching lie to me so I can
talk about your facial expressions
you're like what's Bronstein what's
Larsen what's the Carroll Khan what's
defense
what's chess what's the black pieces why
am I here
okay I can tell that from your facial
expressions all right so white wants to
play e5 and then black would resign
because otherwise you your position is
even worse than resigning losing a piece
okay so they traded on e4 and now if I
play e5 at least you can play Knight d5
since your pawns not there so white has
everything white as an attack white has
two bishops white as the better center
and White's King is perfectly safe I
thought this guy was the four-time US
Champion what happened okay even in 2005
years old
yeah harsh okay Nakamura played a
slightly different style and open
tournaments in open tournaments if you
have four wins and five draws then you
lose five rating points and they shake
your hand and you go home in in the
Sinquefield cop in the US Championship
and the Norway chess when you have four
wins and five draws you win so this is
an open tournament so Nakamura has to
win every game we can't be drawing so a
lot of the games are a little more
swashbuckling okay so Knight FA and now
we see
why the rooks on da attacking the weak
deep on Black has a lot of piece of
defending his king that's not so bad
okay Bishop c4 attacking the new
weakness I tell all of my students and
if I never listen to me I won't teach
them anymore but since they don't listen
I can the same lesson over and over
again okay and if you look at all of
black's pieces and pawns you try to find
ones that aren't defended and usually in
chess there's one or two usually okay so
in this position if we can highlight
okay I do it right or I did it wrong I
didn't say I could do it right but I
could try I think I did it right those
are the four things that aren't defended
and usually when you Castle kingside
this pawn is defended a lot its defended
by a rock and a king but those things
moved away so Nakamura wants to take
this for free that's very easy to defend
yeah I don't see a good way to defend it
okay so g5 counter-attack and this was
the star move of the game I'm sure you
would all play it that means that when
you play it okay so everybody and their
twenty five hundred rated you know
siblings would play Bishop to g3 okay
although then the rooks aren't as good
as they were okay Nakamura played much
more aggressively with this should take
that's that's too aggressive very good
you what you should teach here f4 so now
we have a lot of guys on g5 you must
admit and now with a take our Bishop our
Queens coming into the game because our
plans that on f2 anymore now I actually
play the Queens gambit declined with
white Kaiser only I Castle queenside and
when I do I notice when my F pawn moves
my Queen can go to g2 in the dragon
Sicilian which I'm sure you were all
thinking they they weren't thing in it
when white plays f3 I move seven or
eight the Yugoslavia TAC often white
plays g4 h4 and sometimes the Queen goes
to h2 and you give them the hammer not
the hammer that's in Norway a hammer so
if I can give you a sample variation
let's say he takes this that's a good
sample Wow
or I could Bend Simonet here so let's
let's never go back okay so I think that
was a coincidence so let's say he takes
the bishop I would take the rook
probably you play Knight takes King
takes is illegal King here is risky okay
then I play something like Queen's g2
for example threatening mate and mate
I'm guessing Knight g6 and then I assume
have five wins and I assume Bishop f7
more wins and then on black super
resigns because he's a super Grandmaster
so he resigns differently than you do
okay
so black doesn't want the G file open
but black played g5 so yeah I'll teach
him so he blocked the G file more Knight
G says
five-time US Champion or four-time
something like that okay man I can't
make that joke darn moving on okay so
now this Bishop has attacked a lot for
example Knight takes bishop how that
worked okay now uh in nineteen oh they
don't know and to that even I don't know
every year every two years every two
years the Michigan Chess Association
induct someone into the chest Hall of
Fame
the Michigan chefs Hall of Fame what an
honor I was inducted last year and many
many years ago
Paul Paul Shaw was inducted and he was
he played the 1949 US Championship and
he was rated over 2300 for 50 years he's
still alive it doesn't play anymore
and he gave a speech for some reason and
he said my favorite player ever was
kappa blanka and i found out his chest
secret remember it's important to be
crazy to be good and he said his secret
was he always did things in pairs
understood the power of two every move
he made had two ideas and then his
opponents couldn't wort that so they
would lose okay then they shackled him
up and took him off to the you know your
speeches over okay now knock come we
must have heard that speech because he
made one of those kappa blanka like
moves okay very good move and again it's
the kind of move you wouldn't suspect
because it's a retreat and so white
played a quite at home they can hear you
Bishop II won now the bishops not
attacked this pawns attacked a lot and
we're going to do some discovered attack
on your Queen pretty good square for the
bishop yeah that'll teach his queen to
be there by the way f7 still attack if
you forgot what you did also I did so
this is attacked this is attacked
discovered attack and black didn't like
white didn't sacrifice anything crazy
okay so Shabanov played Knight f4 white
played the most aggressive move ever
that's ever been played
louder nightwear yeah 95 now every piece
is attacked
I'll let Ken West count all of them yeah
you could this is attacked and this and
this and most importantly that all right
now well this isn't defended and this is
attacked and I don't see it square the
Queen can move to that defends the
bishop unless you do there's a lot of
you there's only one of me the most of
you in the top ten okay
so sometimes you got to lose your queen
you hear me talking ken west is like
yeah yeah who can suggest now so okay so
shadow walk took the bishop and then
shadow I've had a choice of taking this
or this he's like wow what a choice ah
mmm I would have taken the rook because
then I'm threatening this rook and this
Knight
although I would have resigned already
um I'm assuming they both get totally
crushed because the night ie one's going
to be trapped you lose your bishop by
the night g2 is a better try still
losing but he took the night because now
he's threatening the rook and the bishop
danny has two pieces for a rook two
pieces for Rick its two pieces for a
queen who dears call me okay drew my
lecture all right so white took the pawn
discovered attack on the bishop so if
you take the rook I'll take the bishop
and then all these pawns are hanging and
the Knights hanging in you're down a
queen so black attacked more with Bishop
before attacking both Rex confusing the
audience the audience is like wait
what's the material here I'm confused
well at least blacks king of sword is
safe but white has a queen for two
nights and the pawns are equal but white
has both rooks hanging the ones defended
so Rick f1 again if you if you take the
rook on g2 I could play rook takes f6
for example where I could go back
several moves because that's what this
computer engine likes to do likes to go
back
okay so if I take the rock don't go back
this time good I would take this
threatening rook h6 rook f7 and queen g2
and I'll up a queen for a rookie tonight
so that's really winning for white okay
so black played rook g e8 now his works
are in the center so blacks doing great
now and a3 attacking the bishop and
Queen f5 attacking the knight and he's
all over black and now it's just a queen
for two nights and some people like me
don't like to resign so black didn't
resign yeah after h4 he's like man
things are getting worse like what
happened over here now of course the
only one that makes any sense is f6 but
due to my rule never play f6 black
resigned very nice good resigning yeah
okay cuz down a queen for two nights
isn't any fun so that was a nice attack
from akaru because well that King looked
really safe I don't think black did
anything that King was just sitting on
b1 all happy that King was on c1 black
would have won a million times over but
I'm b1 nothing does anybody believe me
I believe okay now this is a short game
but it wasn't played by Nigel short the
mysteries of life was Nigel short born
63 64 I'm going to say no wow
69 carry the one I think it was more
than 65 might have been born in 64 but
if he was it was after this is 63 64
right so you at home was was short alive
during Fisher's 11 Oh run okay anyway
this was one of the eleven Oh games
against my pal Benko and your pal - yeah
the delayed reaction very good yeah what
would the guy in litem you say huh okay
so Benko played as passively as possible
giving fish of the center good idea
and this is called the Austrian attack
and the Austria attack Black has several
ways of playing people nowadays like to
castle and place five and Benko played
Bishop g4 most grandmasters nowadays
like their bishops they don't just give
their bishops away like I don't know
then Simon okay
now Bishop g4 is still played today but
it's very rare because white gets a lot
of bishops grandmasters like bishops
more than you do even grandmasters who
play a lot of bug house like bishops
just not a buck house
okay so h3 very similar nakamura game
and now since white was not mikhail tall
heaps looking with the queen and you
know which came i'm referring to typical
class tall Botvinnik one of their fifty
World Championship matches in the
caro-kann I move for one two three I
move 5 tall played G takes f 3 instead
of Queen takes for no reason just then
why not play Bob panic and they drew a
bit very suspicious okay so now they
just play normal chess mastering the
middle game and this is very important
for you and possibly you at home
although you have to wake up you wake up
okay
one guy was asleep okay and wait hold on
one guys it is frigid out let me wait
okay you're back from the fridge
good timing in the positions where you
have pawns on d4 II 4 and f4 which
happens in the Kings Indian in the
Pierce and the modern etc and black
plays e5 there's two standard ways for
white to play you take on e5 one way and
then you push the other pawn so in some
variations you take this way and then
you play d5 but in this variation we're
going to checkmate our opponent because
I was informed that that wins the game
so you take this way and play f5 okay
you always want black to have a pawn
here because then the bishop isn't doing
anything and the knight isn't doing
anything and I have a lot of women who
will tell you I'm the master I'm not
doing anything because oh I know how not
to do anything and of course we could
have the pawn here if you had taken with
the F pawn I hope you're okay over there
kind of lest you see what I did okay but
I mean if you want to check make the guy
it's good to have pawns over there okay
so he took on f5 which I would never
consider and this is like the u.s.
championship and he's better than me
okay I see he's better than me and uh
yeah so I don't I I got nothing I'd
rather have white here because White has
two bishops and the bishop on g7 is
pretty bad but I would never play GF I
would never think of GF okay so Fischer
is like nom yum-yum now we have open
diagonal over here and we got open file
over here half open file actually this
is the half open file and that bishops
still terrible it's blocked by the e
pawn okay
so don't blink because this game ends at
about five moves but some of you blinked
okay Knight to d4 now as I've said many
times and I say the same thing over and
over and over again you still forgot it
when I teach kids and there's a legal
capture they apply it so if I was in
Charlotte or if I was in Nashville which
I'll be in a couple days or two weeks
ago for you right there all right yeah
then then Bishop takes Knight is forest
there is no other move okay but that's
not the best to move because then you
sort of open things up for black you
open up the e-file the bishop gets a
little better the pawns here so what you
just play Queen f2 and show okay sort of
like Netflix but less chillin okay and
then Benko played ninety eight his
knight wants to go to d6
he pretends he wants to play a five he
stops Bishop g5 pinning his knight
castles the only game of the lecture we
Castle kingside
Knight d6 Queen g3 that doesn't look
very nice does it okay so if you
remember not going to his game it was
seven or eight minutes ago when the G
file was open
ciaobella play king h a
and rook g8 he must have learned from
this game he lasted longer than Benko
very impressive okay
and now queen g4 which I like is you
just play Queen g3 that's pretty awesome
c6 doing nothing Queen age five he
wanted the Queen on the h-file since the
king is there but Queen h4 previous move
was very risky so Queen h5 is safer well
this is the problem with not having a
knight on f6 then you don't control h5
usually Knights on f6 and they're not
playing Queen h5 against you that's why
nakamora plays Queen h5 I move to
alright so Queen e8 threatening to
discovered attack and trade Queens and
Black has no problems this should takes
Knight pawn takes and since I have a
blue water it's time to pause those of
you who have seen the game which is most
of you that is getting over there well
know what white played here and I would
probably say two or three of you have
seen the game and you all forgot so
that's good right ken west but you saw
what you forgot yeah exactly
I don't see the threat if you play e5
are you threatening h7 - yes then how
does black stop it maybe f5 then your
Queens attacked by my queen remember in
Nakamura's game there was a bishop on e1
threatening the Queen on a5 now it's the
reverse angle I got one in for Peter
there the Queen 90 it's attacking the
Queen on h5 if you trade Queens and you
think you're going to take my knight I'm
going to take your knight
you're not going to make me when you
trade Queens and if you after f5 if you
take on passant I'll play Queen takes
Queen so after a 5 f5 black is ok now
those of you who know me and are at
least 2,500 strength know that in the
Sicilian Bellamy ravitch attack I like
to play Queen e8 instead of the
theoretical Queen c7 and the reason is
when I move my F pawn I'm attacking your
queen just like here every opening is
the same somehow now Fischer wanted to
meet on h7 but Fischer didn't want black
to play f5 giving the answer away yeah
that's what Ken West would play ah see
very good now it's hard to play f5
unless you do a lot of cheating and when
I play e5 it's going to be really hard
to not get made it what's funny is if
you leave your Bishop here and don't
take my rook then when I play e5 you can
play h6 because you're defending it
although Rick h6 really kills you if you
don't take my rock are your nights
hanging by their way also e5 checkmates
you so real coughs looks pretty good not
not a bad move Benko played King GA his
King will run away through his queen and
rook so for example Bishop f6 when I do
this it's going to go back like 20 moves
just say you know they already did this
once and it went so like what's at
somebody else's lecture
Wow it's good it's gonna I don't know
what's going to happen nothing happened
it happened last time now after E 5
unleashing the latent potential of the
bishop I said that because I saw the a
bit sure about M retain in chess life
today so for those of you who don't know
Emery Tate was one of the funniest guys
ever in pretty good at chess more funny
in every day it was giving a lecture
which means he walked into a room and
just started lecturing himself and
people started listening and my friend
was there and he said the latent
potential of some piece and my friend
said how can a piece have latent
potential what are you talking about and
Henry Tate said if you had more than an
eighth-grade education you would know
the difference between latent potential
and actualized potential and then he
went back to his lecture the friend in
question he was talking it has like four
master's degrees anyway
anyway well the now it's hard to stop me
you know what I mean very hard
you could computer it in like block you
know and then get me to moves instead of
one okay so then cope late yeah there we
go
I'm not sure I'm not sure who won that
bet now yeah I don't know what happened
there okay so black play King g8 then
why play d5 and black play the move this
stops Queen h7 mate age six right now if
the King was on h8 I would play rook h6
here no really now if you play rook h6
maybe black can play f5 again maybe so
Fischer's like hey my Knights attacked I
just noticed that then plate 92 now why
it's going to checkmate you by playing
rook h6 and such but more important than
me why it's going to play rook takes a
knight and usually when your opponent's
up a knight and you're getting mated
that's bad and if you move your night
away because you don't want to lose your
knight right then Queen f5 is annoying
man it's really annoying but nine on d6
stops Queen f5 so as long as black
doesn't move and white doesn't move
blacks okay but if white moves white
takes a free night and if black moves
why
maids him so now you choose a really
cool final move he's like hey my Knights
hanging now I win everything
most people just keep attacking and give
all their pieces away and don't care and
fishers like hey I can attack for free
in fact even the white sacrificed his
rook on f6 his knight on c3 they weren't
captured white was never behind anything
why just started attacking and blacks
like no now when you're getting attacked
on the Kings side and you play King h8
and then King g8 your polygonal lose
probably that's not there right yeah and
so Benko resigned I think yeah and you
did see that game and what book did you
see it and that and then you still were
going to play e5 right when I show it to
you next month what you gonna play I
know the truth hurts okay and last but
not least I'm afraid to leave this
because then Ben's gonna see all this
craziness
it's the craziness no way that's not
that crazy that's okay
okay now this skin I didn't know this is
a game it's a vellum yurevich and
Lubavitch in the Yugoslavian
Championship shocking in 1972 now Vala
Maravich was a wild and crazy player
Steve Martin learned everything he knew
from him and Lubavitch was a better
player but sometimes when your
opponent's wild and crazy they meet you
okay and here white sack all of his
pieces
he thought he was playing bughouse he
was misinformed yeah they played the
crazy Sicilian and you all know the
velum yurevich variation of the what's
it called the classical Sicilian you're
supposed to all say what are you talking
about okay in the Soudan Sicilian when
white plays Bishop c4 when Fischer
played this sozin
also known as the Fischer sozin he would
Castle kingside Val Amira vich would
play Bishop III Queen e2 in Castle
queenside that's the vellum yurevic
attack
that's if black plays Knight c6 black
played a6 which is the night off but
let's look at the game that I would play
or we could just do this and lecture
never ends okay knight c6
cancel when I meant to put insert the
new variation this ship c4 e6 this
should be three this should be three
castles here and this is the velum
yurevic attack invented by vellum
yurevich and he would push all his King
side pawns and meet you then you'd be
like man I lost the last game I lost
that was rated was in this position
against Sam Savion maybe you should
lecture here really I'm serious
yeah and then that's the tournament
where he became a grandmaster he already
had all his Grandmaster Norns we need to
be 2500 feet a now he's like 25 80 feet
okay and that was in November 2014 and
he sacked a piece as quickly as possible
he might have played g4 first but he he
went here as soon as he could and then I
was up a piece like I made it okay so it
was a very smart idea of me to take
America's youngest Grandmaster put the
sharpest line possible okay now
Lubavitch played a6 the knight ourf and
Val Amir which played the sharpest wild
and crazy' line okay this is normal
theory and he played Bishop d3 even
crazier is g4 fact g4 is probably more
common but okay Bishop d3 develops a
piece b5 rip p1 okay
now White was getting very antsy because
white hasn't sacrificed anything yet so
we got a we got start sacrificing it's
not even clear which side black will
castle on good and this looks like a
normal Sicilian position but Sicilians a
dangerous opening sometimes you lose
with one move you miss something and
your pieces all go away
okay so white played Knight to d5 it's
been a while since he's sacrificed
probably since the last game okay and if
you take on d5 you're opening up the
e-file to your king and the night goes
deaf v so that's a little dangerous okay
so he took him with a knight keeping
everything closed and this looks like
we're going to trade a lot of pieces and
blacks King will be perfectly safe now
if Larry Evans was here and he would
look sort of strange he's been dead for
years but if he was here
he would say you got to take pieces you
got to accept the sacrifice
otherwise if I got free a free attack so
I mean if I was black I would just take
this and lose I wouldn't I would not be
a piece up you could be a piece up or
not a piece up so you gotta be a piece
up so you got to take the night and hope
for the best and if that loses then you
go go back to the drawing board and play
better in the opening okay so 9:00 takes
pawn takes white hasn't sacrificed
anything terrible Mitchell takes g5 and
now most of you would recapture without
thinking in fact most of you do
everything without thinking okay I agree
that's good policy but if you recapture
how are you sacking all your pieces if
you want to be down three or four pieces
but you're not really effective can last
experience right you've been down three
or four pieces more than anybody I I
hope yeah exactly
so rook takes a six check just what you
were thinking when my opponent plays
rook takes e6 check and I didn't see it
coming and then I'm laying then this
isn't good this isn't this isn't going
to turn out well for me all right takes
that Knights pretty reasonable on e6
white blacks never get a castle assuming
you know the castling rules if you're
the one o'clock class castle either way
okay so the knight stops castling the
knight threat threatens the Queen the
bishops attacked a lot and whites only
down a rook but those rooks aren't I'm
not scared of those rooks Jack I'm not
scared of any of blacks pieces all right
well the Queen's sort of important so he
moved his Queen shocking and Queen h5
check man this is tough so do I play
King e7 and let him take with check or
do I play g6
and let him make me in win all my pieces
and rooks the answer is fries I don't
know so he played g6 and I would think
Bishop takes g6 is the obvious move but
he played Queen takes g5 I guess he can
play Bishop Dave g6 next move let him
think about it that looks completely
winning whites down a rook but blacks
King is perpetually getting checkmated
okay so he played rook g8 now that's not
special g6 now one of my ex-wives I
don't know which one because they both
play chess when they were black and a
Sicilian they would often play rook g8
and I said don't do that okay and yeah
you're going to find out why okay
although when when they did it it was
even worse this actually stops Bishop g6
check so it has some merit okay rook D -
that's my favorite move of the game okay
white wants to play more fee style rook
e1 with me if you watch every second of
all of my lectures you'll remember in
the Karpov course no lecture from their
candidates mansion 74 that there was a
position where Karpov could play rook e1
which looked really strong but the
refutation was the same as it is here
Queen takes for a checkmate yeah so rook
e1 looks good but like Anna Kournikova
it never wins so Luke's good never wins
alright so instead of rook e1 black
white decided to play rookie - so you
play and rib d2 and the rooks going to
e2 and then that's very annoying and one
of the problems lower rated players have
when they sacrifice material intentional
or not is they're in a big hurry if I
don't meet him right now I'm down a rook
and Bellamy rich isn't in a hurry
because he has this knight on e6 so he's
like wow that Kings there forever
this rooks here forever like I'm just
going to made it when I feel like it the
knight can't go to e5 because there's a
pawn here now this is actually funny
game because Lubavitch is a pretty good
player apply top ten in the world in the
70s in fact when Lubavitch was 61 years
old he beat Akari with black so he's not
a big player and Lubavitch stopped the
attack but he gave so much material away
he was actually lost in the end game
which is pretty funny because if a rook
but you know
you want to get me to have to give some
pieces back ok night f8 that Larsson
approved night takes FA which way should
we take hmm they both looked just
terrible like if you can take with the
king
I got Queen f6 and rookie too if you
take with the rook I got rookie too and
I'm going to e7 so he played Queen d8
yeah I think taking just gets checkmated
Queens e8 now black treats Queens and
black was a rook up was a rock up now
White has a knight and two pawns for a
rook and he still has the same issues so
this is really cute he plays Knight
takes h7 threatening Knight f6 check
trades Queens and now we indirectly
defend d5 because of knight f6 so now
White has a knight and three pawns for a
rook and he's still attacking so it
still White's ahead material now king f7
stopping Knight f6 Knight f6 anyway g3
defending the H pawn discovered defense
age 4 and yeah black could have resigned
because he's almost ready for the next
game okay now the knight one from the
beautiful east six square to the more
beautiful f6 square stopping black from
getting on both open files for his rooks
but that's okay black still has lots of
weak coins so and White has a three to
one pawn majority so we went from a
middle game where we had a big attack
and we're mating to black giving all the
material back to avoid getting mated but
with a dead lost endgame it's too bad
Bishop f5 doesn't really stop the attack
yeah rook it and then yeah alright and
then I actually the way if didn't resign
the arbiter said okay that's enough like
I don't want to see anymore yeah because
you're going to lose this and then
there's some things you don't want to
know important things so that was funny
because vellum yurevic developed all of
his pieces these like alright sack on e6
AK on d5 sack everywhere
and blacks King was just awful and the
other games black actually castled and
it was easy to sort of attack his King
by opening the G file with files and
diagonals here blacks King was in the
center we didn't know which way he would
castle he just opened up the center put
his light on e6 and said you can't
castle now sometimes that doesn't work
and you're just down a lot of pieces
when it does work though it looks great
okay and this is the problem a lot of
people have with our fantastic players
like Moors a [ __ ] and like Bellamy
ravitch and Emory Tate and a lot of
people who are wild attacking players
who win a lot of brilliant games don't
look at their other games that they lost
no we're not looking at those so the
problem is when the attack doesn't work
you're like why that guy give all his
pieces away when you check does work
you're like wow that guy's great okay
and you can learn a lot from the first
match played in 85 85 yeah between
Karpov and Kasparov you had sort of the
boring player versus of the wild
attacking player and after 29 games the
wild attacking player looked so good ok
5 losses in 24 draws you'd expect kiss
rock to win one game out of 29 maybe one
and so sometimes while the attacking
play doesn't work but unlike some of you
white got all of his pieces developed
and put them on the right squares and
then started sacrificing okay
he played rook aid she won Bishop d3 and
then he started wishing his pieces and
there were too many pieces for black to
deal with black eventually evaded the
attack but ended up in a lost endgame
which happens often you get all your
material back and you're just easily
winning and well if you're a novice
player this may not look simple to you
but luckily I can I can dribble it here
because I'm foaming at the mouth looking
at White's position I would be expecting
lots of Queens because yeah you just rip
Knight and pawn just do that if you put
this on an engine if I had an engine I
would show you I probably have an engine
it's going to say something like plus a
it like in your mind it's plus two but
it's it's
it's not yeah alright and Lubavitch
resigned and somehow we've heard of him
and nobody's heard of elam yurevich now
I'm just can you ever have either one
I'm just kidding all right
that's mastering the middle game with
grandmasters so now you're all confused
let's let's split the difference and
just say International mastering the
middle game see you next week